oui c'est bel et bien nous poursuivons
avec
donc lors élise vous êtes donc toutes
les deux représentations ce week end
dans le cadre d'une adaptation de
l'ouvragé d'umberto eco comment voyager
avec un saumon donc c'est une c'est un
livre dirait mode d'emploi en version
acidulées sur le monde d'aujourd'hui
dites nous comment vous est venue l'idée
de mettre en scène ses textes déjà pour
commencer il y avait une envie toutes
les deux travaillé ensemble
d'abord c'est quand même la grosse étape
après il ya eu un gros travail en fait
de création de personnage
on ad'abord voilà créer des personnages
donc je suis je suis marie agnès dupuy
chercheuse au cnrs est pris n'est mon
assistante et et en fait on avait une
envie toutes les deux dalles et voilà
vers un spectacle qui les soignent un
peu critique de notre société et de
montrer comment le quotidien peut nous
bouffer ils savent quand une très grande
femme d'umberto eco que j'avais appris à
connaître c'était que je l' ai connu
grâce à l'émission la grande librairie
sur la 5e et que j'ai tout de suite
ticket aisément en lisant on a trouvé
que ben on appris de plus certaines
parties des modes d'emploi sachs
élections voilà on n'a fait qu'une
couleur avec une petite partie tous ces
modes d'emploi qui était pour nous voilà
ce qu'elle est le plus représenté ce
qu'on voulait à sa déchéance totale on
va dire pour nous parce que c'est des
textes qui sont en train de réalité vue
de cynisme extrêmement corrosif ces
textes là et voilà ça court très bien ce
qu'on avait envie envie d'en faire
d'accord alors peut-être pour illustrer
vos propos on va regarder un petit
extrait donc c'est un extrait qui est
sur la thématique de comment éviter de
parler de foot regarde mais il m'arrive
de regarder un beau match à la télé avec
intérêt et plaisir car car je sais
reconnaître tous les mérites de ce noble
jeu je ne vais pas le foot je jeu elle
est passionnée de foot
comprenez moi bien je nourris envers les
supporters un sentiment identique à à
celui des partisans d'un certain parti
d'extrême droite envers les immigrés
extra communautaires je ne suis pas
raciste
à condition qu'ils restent
marché aux gens tant leur lieu de
réunion en semaine par famille fleuve où
les sag dimanche où je me méfie de ce
qu'il peut arriver où ce n'est pas plus
mal si les hooligans des boules car la
lecture de ces faits divers le divertir
puisque ce sont les jeux du cirque
autant que le sang coule
je n'aime pas le supporters car il
possède une caractéristique étrange
il ne comprend pas pourquoi vous ne
l'êtes pas et les s'obstine à vous
parlez comme si vous l'étiez quelle
difficulté
vous avez rencontré peut-être pas mais
dites nous adapter ces textes qui sont
faits pour les cris de façon dont
chorale et théâtrale le texte dans la
mise en scène mesuré dans la mise en
scène en a eu quand même au départ oui
on a eu des mois les difficultés au
départ ce qu'on a pris conscience de ce
qu'on disait en fait et on avait une
idée plutôt de café-théâtre et on s'est
dit c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible parce que malgré voilà on rit
d'abord mais le fond est beaucoup plus
lourd et beaux mecs trop noir donc on se
dit dans la mise en scène on doit partir
en ascension est arrivé quand même un
but précis et montrer que la société
dans laquelle on vit ne nous plaît pas
et nous prend au corps et nous prend
personnage du copax la mise en scène et
le texte le texte en bouche
umberto eco en plus
mont everest ah oui non non non ça moi
personnellement tanger un déficit voilà
jouer de l'écrit le faire ton enviée
jusque pas vraiment et des poèmes
on a fait un autre spectacle ensemble
professionnel qui était une adaptation
d'un conte philosophique
c'était déjà très écrits mais alors là à
prendre les textes c'est vraiment une
grosse difficulté de mettre en bouche
des phrases qui sont véritablement
parfaite pour l'oral si vous avez un
débit très rapide aussi donc il faut
pouvoir garder ce rythme tout le long je
n'ai pas c'est pas évident on va
regarder un deuxième extrait très court
cette fois ci sur le thème de comment
éviter les maladies contagieuses
il ya très longtemps un acteur de
télévision qui ne faisait pas mystère de
son homosexualité 10 ans jeune mignon
qu'il tente est ouvertement de séduire
tu couches avec des femmes mais tu ne
sais donc pas que c'est cancérigène
elle la boutade est restée célèbre or
l'heure n'est plus à la plaisanterie je
viens de lire sous la plume d'un éminent
médecin que le contact hétérosexuel
provoque le cancer
j'ajouterai que le contact hétérosexuel
province d'avoir toujours tout court
mais mes enfants ne lit en plus cette
union sert à procréer et des cadettes
rené il doit mourir avec un sens étroit
de la démocratie la psychose du sida ne
menaçait de contraindre que les
pratiques sont homosexuels eh bien les
hétérosexuels se retrouvent eux aussi
sous surveillance
et nous revoilà tous égaux ce retour de
la démo nomani nous redonne une
conscience plus stricte de nos droits
c'est de nos devoirs alors vous préciser
aussi que la pièce est plutôt pour un
public à partir de 15 ans un public
plutôt averti pourquoi elles le font et
pour la forme en fait parce qu'on a fait
des choix quand même au niveau des
textes et en mise en scène qui sont un
petit pesé notamment
pour comment reconnaître un film porno
très drôle l'agencé la limite ses 16 ans
je crois
et il ya quand même une explosion à la
fin du spectacle qui peut toucher on
espère du moins mais ma disons que le
spectacle en fait ce qu'on en fait c'est
sous couvert en fait c'est bah c'est du
cynisme et si gluck en ce qu'on amène
sur la fin les idées comme comme tu
disais tout à l'heure c'est le côté ben
comment ça ne supporte plus cette
société là et comment elle nous prend et
on bouffe et nous deux personnages ou
fait totalement par les textes et on
amène des idées sur la fin noir et le
spectacle est noir il est sombre donc il
est très adulte quand même je pense à
entendre après peut-être qu'il y en a 15
ans il aurait aucun problème pour
recevoir après de la même façon je pense
qu'il va y avoir des adultes on l'a déjà
montré
voilà déjà un peu testé autour de nous
aider j'en vois là tout de suite à fond
parce qu'ils aiment le cynisme qu'ils
aiment l'humour noir la nôtre collard de
mal à rentrer dans cette famille mais
c'est pas rentrer c'est juste qu'ils se
prennent en pleine face et qui sont la
glotte aux échos c'est un sommet un des
sommets de la littérature européenne
contemporaine et d'ailleurs je suis très
étonnée qu'on le mette pour le mettre en
scène comme ça j'ai envie d'aller vous
voir et bien vous pouvez donc retrouver
nos deux comédiennes samedi et dimanche
à la salle de la tour à bois et tous est
affiché à l'écran est ce qui va
s'afficher aussi à présent c'est l'agent
d'un voyou tout à fait alors on est un
agenda
ce week end alors déjà j'ai envie de
vous dire si je suis en brocardant un
petit extrait musical esquisseurs ça
doit nous rappeler je pense ce soir
c'est un peu inter générationnelle
pourquoi tranché et bien voilà donc le
groupe génération abat donc donc reprend
évidemment donc les tubes célèbres
d'abba donc se produiront vendredi et
samedi respectivement à vue qui a joué
en josas donc vendredi et samedi
nous avons également pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas su déclarer leur amour
demain puisque demain c'est la saint
valentin petit cours de rattrapage
samedi à la maison de la poésie un
atelier spectacle intitulé iloveyou
leçon numéro une et enfin samedi
toujours un spectacle d'enfants pour
enfants ou pas qui s'appelle alice and
broad donc tiré du fameux alice au pays
des merveilles donc c'est une adaptation
très libre et ça se joue à coignières
merci beaucoup
aurélien pour cette page culture on vous
retrouve mercredi prochain merci à nos
invités 10 sont venus ce soir nous
parler de leurs activités respectives et
puis au début de cette émission je vous
parlais du 4l trophy de cette expédition
qui va des partir donc que demain avec
des étudiants de 18 à 28 ans à travers
l'espagne le maroc qui les amèneront des
fournitures scolaires ces étudiants avec
elle avec l'aide de leur 4l justement il
ya des équipages yvelinois qui sont
engagés je vous conseille donc de vous
rendre sur notre site internet pour en
savoir un petit peu plus et à
re-découvrir le ce portrait préparer à
part anthony rech et elodie moines
on se retrouve demain 18h pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 toujours en
direct avec de nouveaux invités
non